so I saw you're going to be at for many
rows on Twitter I was like oh my
goodness grandma can I come pick you up
and take you somewhere as a surprise and
she's like okay am I gonna see anyone do
I need my earrings and I look taken and
so your blog is called older than Oscar
and why is that because I'm Oscar is 85
and I'm 86 a couple of inches away from
87 I understand you're an enormous movie
fan you watch how many moves do you see
prieur oh it's about 85 or 90 movies per
year yes I don't know that I've seen
that in 10 years I was a huge number oh
well I don't work that helps it helps
clear up some time yeah what would you
do if you were able to actually see an
Oscar or hold enough I really no I don't
care the Academy decided this year that
they wanted to try to find the biggest
fans of movies across the country and
bring a bit of an Oscar experience to
that were with the Academy I thought I
thought it was at school that we have
you I was a school journalist know what
they know it that we have something
called the neighborhood Academy yeah
allegiant you thought that was what was
the word the academy of motion picture
arts and sciences you think it's amazing
but big of a movie fan you are we would
like you to meet Oscar oh come on oh no
why did I say no of course I very heavy
Oh Oscar haha Oh honest to pee why did I
say no it doesn't matter you got about
the answer is yes I want to touch Oscar
you want to say anything to all those
movie fans up
will read up read my my a blog I've done
by my granddaughter Natalie Stewart
published by your granddaughter written
by you Oh a good way of phrasing thank
you older than Oscar com be honest with
you about one thing though you might be
older than Oscar you look much younger
than us oh well thank you i would i
would have thought you were 15 20 years
younger than the Academy Award thank you
I'm lucky very lucky like a good trait
good genes are genes yeah I'll
Samantha's even wear pants of any kind